it is time for this week's pet project
lori herron joins us from the nspca and
she brought along someone who needs a
safe
and good home how you doing lori i'm
great
hi kendall and hey at nevada spca
everywhere
in fact all across the country we are
celebrating national
dog day and what national dog day is
it's a reminder
of all kind all the breeds and all the
dogs
that are in need of rescuing either by
nevada spca or all the other
wonderful rescue groups in our community
that help save
dogs and in honor of national dog day i
have nevada spca's fabulous
dog care evaluator and enrichment
coordinator this is isaiah
and isaiah is also here today because
our dog
kratos who's right now on the floor come
on kratos get up there you go
kratos is in love with isaiah so i think
i had to be here in order for us to show
you
kratos today kravis is a four and a half
year old
um bully mix and he um
like i said he loves isaiah but he is
very loyal and he will bond with you can
you stand your pretty face there buddy
and uh come on kratos
thank you and he if you were to adopt
kratos he needs a lot of activity
um he is on some daily medication for
his allergies but it's not a big deal
and again he has bonded with isaiah and
other
people at our shelter and we know that
he will bond with your family
um if you give him a chance and give him
your loving forever home kendall
do you know if he's good around kids and
other animals
we think that he's okay with older kids
but we don't believe we don't recommend
that he's with any other animals
um oftentimes at nevada spca we don't
really know what the answer is so we
make
our best recommendation uh he is about
80 pounds
uh he is a gentle soul but requires a
lot of activity so our best
recommendation right now kendall
is that he's on his own um but he can be
with older kids
okay all right lori always good to see
you great to see you kendall
if you're interested in adopting a pet
go to nevadaspca.org
and call them or you can call them at
that number on your screen
is